KOH KIM: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU:
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
KOH KIM: Wait a minute.
Our audience probably can
only speak English, right?
They're not on YouTube--
not like the YouTube guys
who can turn on auto-translate.
So let's switch
to English, right?
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: OK.
KOH KIM: All right.
Hi everyone.
Good morning.
So my name is Koh Kim.
I'm part of the Google Play
business development team
here in Mountain View,
focused in games.
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: So
I'm Yoshi, based in Tokyo.
I'm doing the Google
Play's apps and games.
KOH KIM: Today, we're
here to talk to you
about how to go global
with Google Play.
As you've known from yesterday's
many various announcements,
Google Play is a really,
really big marketplace.
And so this morning,
we're here to talk to you
about how to take
advantage of that.
But what are some of the
best practices and tips
to go to a lot of
those foreign markets?
So let's just get
a general idea.
So how many of you have come
here from outside the US?
Wow, that's a lot of you.
Asia?
Europe?
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: Cool.
KOH KIM: South America?
Brazil?
Really?
Why are you here to begin with?
The world's biggest
sporting event
is happening in
Brazil right now.
I just came from there.
I don't even know why I'm here.
But that's amazing.
Thank you for being here today.
I'm really excited
to have you here.
So let's just take
a look at what
the current world of Google
Play looks like right now.
Those marked in
green-- Google Play,
people all over the
world from 190 countries
download and install apps on
Google Play every single day.
Those marked in
green are actually
some of our largest markets
not only by install base
but also by revenue.
And what's really cool is
that it's not just the US.
I mean, there's markets all
over the world for many of you
probably in the countries
that you've come from.
And then we'll also talk
about a little bit later
what some of our fastest
growing markets are.
So this is an example of some
of the most popular games
in the US on Google Play today.
And developers from
all over the world
are actually finding success.
Those marked in
blue are obviously
companies that are based outside
the US-- in Europe, actually--
and in Asia, the Asian companies
are also marked in red.
So that's at least a third of
these-- a third of these titles
have come from developers
outside the US.
So what does it take
to expand your business
outside of your domestic
market and into the US,
or in some other markets today?
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: All right.
expect It's expected in
my home country, Japan.
So possible you
go to the global,
or go to the specific
countries, so first of all,
you need to know the users.
What's the users' behaviors?
So this is-- my country
is Tokyo from outside
of the Tokyo to the commute
to the center of Tokyo.
So in the trains, in dealing
with people's commuting,
people, what are they doing is
they've got the [INAUDIBLE].
They're touching
their smartphones.
And probably they're
playing games,
or probably they're
messaging on their phones.
So understanding the users
is pretty important things
as possible.
KOH KIM: So Yoshi, what's the
average time someone in Japan
spends commuting each day?
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU:
So average commute time
is like 60 minutes,
only one way,
in the trains--
probably the same
as from here, city, to
the Mountain View, right?
KOH KIM: Yeah.
That's about it.
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU:
You had a commute--
KOH KIM: Well, yes.
I do have to commute.
Sometimes it's an
hour and a half.
But I'm driving, right?
So I can't necessarily drive
and play games at the same time.
That probably wouldn't
work out too well.
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU:
Totally different deal.
In here, the commute
is drive or by car,
but in Asia it's taking
the trains in a commute.
That's totally different, and
the users are different, too.
KOH KIM: So think about it.
Two hours a day, five days a
week-- that's 10 hours a week,
times a month, that's 40 hours.
That's a lot to game
time just in a train.
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: Right.
KOH KIM: So let's
take a look at some
of the most popular
games by market.
Yoshi, you want to
talk a little bit
about what we see
in Korea and Japan?
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: So in
Asia, a pretty popular game
is the casual games.
So cute, the animal titles,
and then casual or super
casual games.
And then several
times, the people
are tending to playing--
some people are tending
to playing the hardcore games.
And in Japan, it's more
like some game system
combined-- like casual game plus
casual game plus monetization
systems.
We call like me
casual games in Japan.
How about the Western countries?
KOH KIM: Same in the
Western countries.
So in the US, it's
pretty well diversified.
I mean, people will play
a wide variety games,
from casual Match 3
all the way to some
of the more strategy,
simulation-- some of the farms
and building games and
a lot of that stuff.
But if you look in
Europe-- especially,
let's say, in Germany and
Russia where some of our biggest
markets are-- it's a little
bit more interesting.
You definitely see more of that
military, that medieval-esque,
really hardcore themes
that are coming around.
Like in Germany, they're really
all about that medieval fantasy
themed games, a lot of deep
strategy that's involved,
which is pretty apparent.
And then also, they love their
football simulation games.
I've never seen so many
football simulation games
in my life-- football,
soccer, depending
on which country in
the world you're from.
If you look in
Russia, they really
like their tank games and
their army games and things.
But that's what's
really interesting.
If you look at a
lot of these games,
the same game play
elements pretty much
resonate across the board.
You have a lot of RPG
elements, a lot of, let's say,
building characters,
going on adventures.
A lot of those
themes are the same.
It's just the way
that they present
it is a little bit different.
So now that you have an
idea of what types of games
are popular in each of
these markets and especially
around the world,
do you have a game
that you think
can be successful?
And if so, what do
you need to change,
whether it's how do you present
that game to your audience
or do some changes so you
can be successful for all
of those markets?
It's really just pretty simple.
We kind of break it
down to three things.
First, it's really
about how do you
acquire those users
to begin with?
How do you convince
them, hey, you
need to install my game
because it's awesome?
So we'll talk a
little bit about that.
And then the second is how
do you connect with that user
when they first get into game?
What is that on boarding
experience like?
How do you get them
hooked to begin with?
And then finally,
it's how do you
get those players to come back?
How do you retain those
players beyond the first week,
but actually turn them
into a lifetime player?
So let's start
with the first one.
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: Mhm.
KOH KIM: So this is an image
of what the Google Play
store looks like today on device
and also on the desktop web.
What are some of the things that
you notice-- the first thing
that a user is going to see?
Well, it's clearly
the icons, right?
So let's take a look at some of
the different icons by market.
Do you notice some
slight differences just
from looking at
the US and versus,
let's say Asia, specifically?
Well, in the US, you actually
see a lot more realistic
character designs, and
also a mix of-- there's
male characters, there's
also monster characters.
So they don't really latch
on to a different thing.
And then if you look
in Korea, for example,
it's actually a lot cuter.
You see that more anime,
manga visual style elements.
And so they've really
focused on cute characters,
unless you're a sports game.
That's probably a little
weird if you focused on that.
But Yoshi, what is it
like in the rest of Asia?
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU:
So in Japan,
obviously the dragon is
pretty famous in there.
So put the dragons in the icons
is pretty popular right now.
It's the top
revenue-grossing chart.
And also, one more
trending Japan
is some cute cat in the icons.
It's also pretty
popular in Japan, too.
And also in Taiwan,
as well as Hong Kong,
is the Three Kingdom story is
pretty popular theme in there.
That's pretty popular.
KOH KIM: Lot of Three
Kingdoms, right?
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: Yeah.
KOH KIM: Everyone likes
cats all over the world.
It's just whether it looks like
a real cat or a cartoon cat,
right?
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: Yeah.
In Japan, everyone's using
a cat for the games themes.
All right.
So we're just talking
about the icons.
Then usually after you see the
icons, what the user will see
is your game titles.
So this is an example of the
Clash of Clans and Candy Crush,
how to get in to
the Japan market.
So the original
game's name is Clash
of Clans in the
English versions.
Then they changed to
the Japanese version
is-- they make it the Japanese
name of the Clash of Clans
plus the original names.
That's what the [INAUDIBLE] did.
And also, the Candy Crush
Saga is more tremendous
changing the Japan market.
And then they changed it.
The title's name is
the only Japanese.
And also, they took off
the Saga from their titles
for the Japanese
market, because a saga
is pretty-- doesn't
make sense in Japanese.
So they took the Saga.
Then they called it Candy
Crush in Japanese only.
That's what they said.
So right now, the
title is pretty
important after the icons.
KOH KIM: So after the
players take a look
at the icons and the titles--
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: Screenshot.
KOH KIM: --the next thing
is a screenshot, right?
If you think about the Google
Play store listing, that's
the next thing they're
going to look at.
So this is an example
of a game in the US
of what screenshots
look like to US players.
Visual style's a little
bit different in the West.
It's definitely more
focused on the game play.
It's really simple.
It kind of shows-- it gives
the player a better idea
what the in-game experience
is going to look like,
or what the inside
of the application
is going to look like.
But meanwhile, in Japan--
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU:
Here you go.
Well, It's totally different
from the Western titles.
The Asian title screenshot
is using more bright and many
of the characters
[INAUDIBLE] and try
to make it more like-- not
only the game scenes, also the
[INAUDIBLE] providing
more what the user can
play in the world of the games.
That's the important
things in Asia.
And also, in the
Google Play, you
can change the screenshot,
also the icons,
and you can change it in
there for each country.
So you provide
the-- probably they
tweak those screenshot
for Asian market
as well as the US market.
KOH KIM: So now
you got an idea how
to create the best store
listing for your game
in order to get those users
to install those games.
Now that you've
got them to install
your game, which is awesome,
let's go to the next step,
is how do you get them hooked
onto your game to begin with?
So in that sense-- well, even
before we even get to the game,
let's just talk about
mobile networks.
It's really important
to understand
each of your local
markets, but especially
what their mobile infrastructure
is actually looking like.
This is an example of
me-- I downloaded a game.
It's called Ace
Fishing from Com2uS.
And it's actually a
pretty good fishing game,
but some of these games
actually just requires
a constant network connection.
So you can imagine when I
was in Brazil, sometimes
with all that many
people, the connection
can be somewhat unreliable.
I get this notice
that says, hey, we
don't see that your device
is connected to a network,
so we are not going to let
you play the game at all.
So you can imagine a
user for the first time,
if they have no idea that
you need a constant network
connection in order
to play the game,
you can tell it's
probably not going
to be a great user experience.
And so we definitely
encourage you
to do either one of
two things-- first,
definitely note in your
description on your Google Play
store listing if your game does
require a network connection
in order to actually
play the game.
And then second, if you have
a constantly connected network
game, one of the things
you may want to consider
is an offline mode or another
game mode or an app mode
so that a user can still
do things within the game.
But as soon as they get to and
actually connect to a network,
then they can start continuing
that game experience.
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: Right.
KOH KIM: So let's
talk about what
UI and navigation looks like.
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: Yes.
This is the pretty
popular games in Japan.
And I'd like to explain
about the UI stuff
and what's popular
in the Japan market.
So this is the-- those two
titles, Puzzle & Dragons
and [INAUDIBLE], which
is the number one
and number three in the
top gross revenue in Japan.
And the important thing
is, as I explained
before, Japan has
the commute culture.
So basically,
those game is plans
and making for the days
commute trains cultures,
which is more [INAUDIBLE] mode.
And so as possible, they play on
[INAUDIBLE] mode for the game.
And also they put
as many information
as much as possible
in the one screens.
But it's pretty complicated
information in the one screen,
but the user is pretty easy to
navigate in the one screens.
For example, the one
thumb fingers, then user
can do whatever they
want in the one screens.
That's the important
things in Japan.
How about the American style?
KOH KIM: In the American style?
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU:
Western style.
KOH KIM: The American style, you
can see a lot of games actually
have a landscape mode, mostly
because it looks prettier.
Most people are used
to landscape mode.
If you think about how people
have played games or interacted
with applications to
begin with, mostly it
was on TV or desktop screens.
So that's clearly
landscape mode.
But if you look at a lot of
the navigation and UI elements,
they definitely take a backseat
towards within the game play
experience-- a lot simpler,
a lot cleaner UI look.
If you want to access certain
other game trees or profiles,
you actually have
to go to that file.
It opens up another
screen-- rather than,
let's say, in some
of the Asian games,
you can quickly go to different
parts of different modes,
different sections of the game
would just all in one screen.
So it's a little bit different.
That's just how-- if you
think about game play times,
it make sense.
People prefer the simple
and more cleaner looks.
But let's also talk about
in-game localization.
So we're going to go to an app.
We're going to take a
break and go to an app.
So I do you understand
you guys are here.
If you're big soccer,
football fans,
I know there's the
US/Germany match going on.
So I actually, before,
went to Brazil.
I actually used
Duolingo to learn
a little bit of
Brazilian-Portuguese
so that I wouldn't be completely
lost in that country trying
to find my way to that stadium.
And so what was really
interesting is that Duolingo,
it's a foreign
language learning app.
And what they did
is that they made it
a very consistent experience,
but they made sure
when they localized
in-game for not only a US
user but also a German
user, that they're
using the right words, the
right font style, and everything
consistent across the board.
So any US or German can actually
learn some Brazilian-Portuguese
before heading to the matches.
So what's really cool about
Google Play is in the developer
console, it actually does
provide some localization tools
for you to get started.
You can get professional
translations directly
through the APK
translation service.
That's found in the
developer console.
Or alternatively, you can
also use a translator toolkit
to upload your strings,
XMS files, XML files,
and a translation
engine can actually
create localized
versions of that file.
So we do provide a
lot of tools in order
for you to get
started in localizing
a lot of those markets.
And clearly, you can see, I
can either be a US or German
and then learn
Brazilian-Portuguese.
So, next slide.
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU:
In Asia, the line break
is pretty important
in the Asian market.
So this is the example of the
line break, correct version
and the incorrect versions.
So the above one in Japanese
is, [SPEAKING JAPANESE].
This is the correct version.
And right side is how to look
like from the user perspective
is, nice to meet you.
My, line break, name is Kim.
It's pretty natural
in the above side.
But an incorrect version
is [SPEAKING JAPANESE].
This looks like,
nice to meet you.
My na, line break, me is Kim.
So, from the user
perspective, this
is the-- I'm not using
the unnatural Japanese
or unnatural Asian
languages, is the user
feel like, OK, this game is
not customized for my country,
for my languages.
Then user easy to
leave the games.
So the retention is using
the right line break
in the game, is pretty
important thing.
KOH KIM: But this also
applies to the West
as well, and vice versa.
So if you think
about-- especially
if you're trying to think
about your navigation
buttons and your menu buttons.
Asian languages are a lot more
condensed language format,
versus, let's say,
a Western language.
That can take a lot of room.
So you want to be aware of
what your menus look like,
what your buttons
look like, and then
just the amount of text that
shows up within the screen.
Because the last thing you want
is text to run over the button.
It would look really weird,
regardless of whether you're
from Asia or the US.
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: So we
recommended that you check in--
so after you finish the
translation localization,
then check in and
then they ask you
did you make the local
language the native speakers,
and then check in if it
looks like a native or not.
All right, fun part.
KOH KIM: Fun part.
Let's talk about how you
actually retain and make money,
right?
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: All right.
So in here, do you know
the Gotcha System in here?
KOH KIM: Gotcha.
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: Gotcha.
KOH KIM: Anyone?
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: OK.
I hope.
So I'd like to show you
how the Gotcha works
in the game in here.
KOH KIM: So you're going
to turn on the demo?
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: Yep.
I'd like to do the demo.
So in Asian games, especially
in Japan games, so--
KOH KIM: You're going to
show everyone your password.
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: Yup.
All right.
So I'd like to show the
Puzzle & Dragons demo in here.
And I'd like to show them how
to work the Gotcha in the games.
So Gotcha is get the chance
to get the strong icons
or strong characters
in the games.
No, they're guaranteed to
get the icons in the games.
That's a different part.
Let's hit start.
KOH KIM: So in other
words, it's a lottery.
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: Yeah.
KOH KIM: OK.
How many of you are familiar
with Puzzles & Dragons?
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: OK.
KOH KIM: Oh good.
OK.
So just explaining
for those that are not
aware of Puzzles &
Dragons, it's developed
by a Japanese developer, GungHo.
It's a Match 3 RPG
game that I was saying.
So Yoshi's going to show you
one of the common mechanics
that we use to get users
hooked into this game.
You fight monsters in dungeons.
You collect them and
you build them up.
In order to get new monsters,
you have to go to this dragon
that offers-- so we
have gift cards--
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: So
I have gift card here
for this during the discussion--
KOH KIM: Because we want some.
Because in order to progress
through the dungeon,
it's actually a lot easier
to have more powerful eggs.
What is this one?
How do you like it?
No?
not good enough?
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU:
Not good enough.
KOH KIM: It's not
good enough for him,
so we're going to try again.
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: Try again.
So this is a special
collaboration
with the Japanese
famous anime in here.
Eh, [INAUDIBLE].
KOH KIM: That's still
not good enough for you?
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: It's--
I think it's not enough.
Let me try one more.
KOH KIM: He has
very high standards
for what types of
monsters he wants.
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU:
I want a golden eggs.
KOH KIM: Try.
Nope.
It's another silver.
I don't think you're
going to get it.
Try again?
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: Once more.
KOH KIM: One more?
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: One more.
KOH KIM: OK.
One more?
All right.
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: One more.
I think it feels like
I can get the gold--
KOH KIM: Are you feeling lucky?
Here we go.
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU:
Here you go.
KOH KIM: Not a thing.
I don't think it's
happening for you.
One more?
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: One more.
KOH KIM: OK.
This is the last
chance, hopefully.
KOH KIM: Are you sure you have
enough credit in your account
to do this?
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: Uh, yes.
This is the last.
KOH KIM: Last chance?
All right.
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: Here we go.
Oh.
Silver.
KOH KIM: I don't
think it's your day.
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: OK.
KOH KIM: OK.
KOH KIM: How much money
did you just spend?
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU:
$25 in three minutes.
KOH KIM: In three minutes?
I wish I could make that
return in three minutes.
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU:
Anyway, that's
the Gotcha system in Japan.
So it's not only-- this
kind of the Gotcha system
isn't only in this
system in Japan,
but the popular games
is making the decisions
to making the monetizations.
And then they tweak
the game balance
with the what character
is in the games.
So when they're
making the characters,
then they're thinking
about how to affect
those characters in the games.
KOH KIM: So what
about in the West?
So in the West, it's a
little bit different.
Free to play mechanics
are-- those games
are more focused on
gradual learning curves.
So I remember when I first
played Puzzles & Dragons.
Within five minutes,
they were telling me,
this is the dungeon system,
this is how do you get Match 3s.
Also, if you want to get better
combos, you have to do this.
And they kind of
smash everything
in within the first
three dungeons,
which is supposed to
be 5 to 10 minutes.
So whereas in the West, a lot
of the games, especially a lot
of these premium
games, they kind of
introduce these new features
and game modes very piecemeal.
It's more gradual
learning curves.
They want you to
experience, OK, get an idea,
once you understand,
oh, match three things.
Oh, if you match multiple
then you get a combo.
And so it's a different
learning curve
in a lot of those
games in the West.
And also, a lot of
these common game
play mechanics that you see, and
especially what they monetize,
is not necessarily based
on the lottery system.
Well, there's some basis
on the lottery system,
but the focus is mostly
more on building--
on building items and
characters and buildings
of permanent value.
And so this is
actually a screenshot
of Tiny Dice Dungeon
from Kongregate.
They focus-- one of their
best monetized mechanics
is actually building new dice.
So this game is all about,
you get better dice in order
to get better attack rates,
so sort of like a lottery,
but not really.
But what's interesting is that
you can build better dice so
that you have higher
chances of, let's say,
a certain elemental
damage attack or higher
critical damage
and a lot of stuff.
But in order to get those dice,
you have to put in more money
to get these different
shards in order
to create those
more powerful dice.
And so this is actually what
a lot of premium currency
is focused on, and
especially the monetization
among Western
players, because they
want to give these players
something that they can keep
versus a chance of getting
something that can be valuable.
So two totally different things.
Last thing.
Prices.
And so we really
want to emphasize
during your research on prices.
People, if you look at-- this is
the difference between dollars
and euros, and I
think even in Europe
they don't use a lot of
nines anyway, but especially
in the US, a lot of
prices end with nines.
I don't know why.
There's a pricing
study on this if you're
really curious on why this is.
But if you look
in Korea and Asia,
everything ends with zeros.
So that's something
you want to check,
because if you have a price
that ends with a nine or even
any other digit, it's
going to look really
strange to any player
or any user that's
trying to purchase any items.
They're going to
think something's
wrong with the game,
and so they're not
going to end up
purchasing to begin with.
So what's great
about the developer
console is that we do have
a currency conversion tool.
You can input your main--
whatever your primary currency
is-- and then you
can see how that
will convert in each
and every currency
where we actually
sell into that market.
And so you can modify in a
lot of that for each market
as you want.
But these are just
some of the tools
that we have available
in order to make sure
that your game or
your application
is locally relevant
to that user.
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: Yeah.
In your main
countries, you should
make sure they manually
put the price [INAUDIBLE]
in your games.
That would be great
for the users as well.
KOH KIM: Next one.
So let's talk about
the last part,
is now that we've got
their players hooked
within the game,
let's talk about how
do you get them to come
back, and keep coming back.
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: So,
this is the Com2uS games,
which is the Korean
game, [INAUDIBLE]
in the Japan market.
So what they are doing is they
are doing the user support
in the local languages
in Japan, which
is the user can comment whatever
about the games in the user
view, and the contacts get
the-- this is a good chance
to reply to the user's comment
and the support the users,
and then get more good
retention from the users.
So this is a pretty
good example in Japan,
and what the outside of
the Japanese developers
are doing in the user support.
KOH KIM: And to know Com2uS
is actually a developer.
They're based in Korea.
And so they actually do
this for English as well.
And so for a lot of
developers, coming in,
talking to, and speaking,
responding to your user
in their local language
makes it that much better,
and they respond a lot better.
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU:
And the user
is thinking about, oh,
these guys are supporting
in their local languages, and
then, OK, I can trust them.
And then they play
more in the game.
That's important things.
And next one, as the
little tweak point
is, but the notification is
an important thing as well.
From the user perspective,
this is the [INAUDIBLE] portal.
They don't forget to localize
the entire notification
in the notification bar.
So the subject is in
Japanese in this example,
but still the text
is still in English.
And the user realizes, oh,
this is not localized perfectly
in Japanese in the
local language.
So this might be-- the user
will probably think about, OK,
should I leave the game
or should I stay in there.
But that's the point, is don't
forget everything's localized
in the notification as well.
KOH KIM: This is true if you
have a content update, right?
You've worked so hard to
make all this new game
mode or new content,
and then if you finally
push to users-- but if
they don't understand
what you just pushed,
then it defeats the point.
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU:
Something update, OK?
KOH KIM: All right.
Let's talk about
purchase patterns.
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU:
So this is the one tip
for entering the Japanese
market and the Asian market.
So our deal is that we can see
the many monthly limited peak
in once in a month.
So because--
KOH KIM: And why is that?
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: Why?
Because we provide several
form of payment methods
for the Japanese users, one, as
a credit card, two, as a gift
card.
I showed you guys, and sort
as data carrier billing.
And then Japanese
users are allowed
to use the data calibering.
That's making it once in a
month their peak revenues.
And the data carrier
billing has the limitation
of the users in the month, which
is that everyone is spending
the money in the month, and
then attaching the limitations.
Then they cannot buy anymore.
KOH KIM: So when
does it refresh?
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU:
So refresh timing
is first of the
month in Japan time.
So after you refresh
the limitations,
then a user immediately
tried to buy the contents.
Then the Japanese developer
knows about [INAUDIBLE].
Then they make it
a special event
for this target, once a month.
So that's why.
Users, once you buy
and the developers
providing the good contents
and the super layer contents
in the months, then
making big revenues
in the Japanese market.
That's a little bit, the
tips for the Japanese market.
KOH KIM: And this is
not in Japan as well.
I mean, a lot of other
markets, like Korea
and even some markets in
Southeast Asia, a lot of people
don't have credit
cards, or they don't
tend to use credit cards to make
purchases for digital items.
And so they'll actually use
their mobile phone or carrier
billing, or they use gift cards.
So it's actually really
good to understand not only
how a user plays but actually
how they actually do purchases
online.
Because they'll help you better
position a lot of your items
and a lot of your
monetization mechanics,
especially within
the game or app.
So the thing is, is not only
is it important to understand
purchase patterns, but
it's also to understand
what types of holidays
or seasonal content
you can do to
bring players back.
And so Valentine's
Day is clearly
a holiday that's celebrated
almost everywhere in the world.
And so creating any
content based on that
is a great way to kind
of get users into game.
This is an example of Badland.
They've made special
levels to include
more of the Valentine's
Day content.
And so it's a good way to
delight your users coming in.
But then we can even talk
about super local stuff.
So let's talk about in Japan.
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: In
Japan, so back to the school
season in the US is
September, right?
KOH KIM: Yep.
Late August, and September.
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU:
That's the-- everyone's
making a campaign in their
games or in the applications
in the US market.
But back to Asia,
back to the schools,
the campaign is the--
actually happens in April.
So everyone's making games or
campaigns in the end of March
through to April.
That's a different thing
in the local market.
And also, I would like to
mention about the long holiday
stuff.
And in Asia, for
example, the bottom one
is the Golden Week campaign in
Japan, which is the long spring
break in May, in Japan,
and as well as Korea.
And that thing is
the long vacation
is specific for the
Japan and Korea market,
and then we make
in the campaign--
the developers
make it a campaign.
That's the different
thing on the other side
of the Western market.
KOH KIM: Being aware
of these seasons
is actually very
important by region.
I mean, I was just in
Brazil, and if you push out--
and it's actually
technically winter
there because it's in
the southern hemisphere.
So if you actually push
out a summer-themed content
like with beach volleyballs
and all that stuff,
it's not going to make
sense because it's actually
in the fifties and
raining and dark.
So--
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: Summer
campaign in the winter.
KOH KIM: Summer
campaign in winter.
Yeah, that's probably not
going to make too much sense.
So it's very important
to be aware of that,
especially understanding
where your users are
around the world.
Make sure if you're going
to push out seasonal content
that it's definitely
relevant for that region.
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: All right.
So our next step is, so
I talk to other users
into the game is collaboration
with the well-known IP license.
So this is an example of
the Japanese game Puzzles
& Dragons.
So they tried to make in
the-- tried to acquire
new users to use the famous
well-known IP collaborations.
The right size is-- they
collaborate with Dragonball,
and then users can actually
play the Dragonballs characters
in a game.
They make many new users coming
back to Puzzles & Dragons.
And left side is [INAUDIBLE].
They collaborate with
[INAUDIBLE] as well, and then
making some campaigns and
then special dungeon in there.
And hopefully--
KOH KIM: --get more users.
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: They
can get more users in there.
So collaborate with the
well known IP license
stuff is pretty good
way to acquire new users
in Japan market, and in
Korea market as well.
KOH KIM: So that IP
actually doesn't only
have to be fictional.
They can actually be
real life as well.
And so in Korea there's a really
big celebrity K-pop culture.
Actually, Nexon has decided to
do a special campaign with one
of the very popular K-pop
girls band called Girl's Day.
And they decided to build
kind of like their almost
in-game-- they build
an in-game character
version of all the
Girl's Day characters
for one of their MMORPG games.
And so it's actually
pretty interesting.
It's just like
getting more users in,
understanding that a lot
of the users in that region
really enjoy K-pop.
They really follow a lot
of those celebrities.
And so having them
be able to purchase
and even get a
chance to even get
some of these characters in
their game or their arsenal
is very, very attractive to
a lot of these users as well.
So it actually
doesn't stop here.
We've only talked
about this whole thing
about acquiring, engaging,
and entertaining a player.
It's only a single player.
So we're going to
talk about what
happens when you get a lot
of those players coming in
at once.
And so you get some very
interesting trends and new game
play mechanics that
emerge, once not only you
get more powerful devices
and really reliable networks,
but then you have tons
and tons of players
that are playing games or
interacting with applications.
So let's take a look at
what's happening in Japan.
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: All right.
So those two titles are getting
pretty popular in the Japan
market.
And what they are
doing is the location
based API plus
real-time match players.
Real-time match player is
getting popular globally,
but those two
titles you can play
with real friends,
close friends.
And you can choose--
the one title
is you can choose the close
friends or the network friends,
and the one title is
only for playing together
with new friends only.
But the playing with a new
friend with real-time match
player is getting
popular right now.
And also the right side is
Slingshot Braves by COLOPL
and they are doing the sandbox
in there on this second floors,
and then you can
ask the COLOPL what
are they doing in the games.
And then you can play the
big screen games right now
in sandbox.
KOH KIM: So then when
devices get more powerful,
this kind of what happens.
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: Yeah.
As I explained,
the Japanese games
is pretty casual games and
then casual games combined,
but it's getting more
and more hardcore games
getting popular as well.
This is not the PC online game.
This is the game
for the Android,
and they provide by the
[INAUDIBLE] name is [INAUDIBLE]
and they're using the
[INAUDIBLE] engines.
And then those kind of the
match player hardcore game
is getting popular in Asia,
not only Japan and not only
Korea, in some other
Asian market as well.
KOH KIM: But as mobile gamer,
as the audience expands,
especially when we have one
billion plus devices out there,
it actually kind of gives
you more opportunities
for different game
genres to come up.
And so, for some reason,
a lot of these games--
you'll see High
School Story, and this
is Episode-- that are kind
of reinventing this genre.
And it's called slice-of-life
and the drama genre in games.
If you can remember, dating Sims
are actually a very popular PC
game genre in Asia,
but they haven't really
gained a lot of
traction in the US
with the exception of the Sims.
But you don't actually see a
lot of that in mobile games.
And so if you think about how--
almost half of our audience
is female, but then
a lot of these people
are going to enjoy these
different types of games
genres.
So it's a really
interesting to see
what new types of
genes and applications
there are outside of
their traditional action
RPG and a lot of that
hardcore elements
that are arising in
the market right now.
And what's also interesting is
that because it's not just one
player, it's about many players
coming together and building
communities around their games,
you see really interesting,
I would say, not just game
play, but interactions
that are occurring
within the game.
Quiz Up, which is
the game on the left,
they actually have a discussion
forum for all of their players
that are happening online,
and all these players actually
come in and talk about
all the different topics,
about the quiz topics, and
they actually talk about,
let's say, physics
or their favorite TV
shows and all that stuff.
And so it's very interesting
to see the types of engagement
that happens just by
having a discussion
forum or a real-time chat
feature within the game.
And then if you look
at High School Story,
they actually allow
you to connect
all of those in-game characters
with your real life friends.
And so it actually brings
this extra personal touch.
I mean, imagine re-imagining
the high school life
that you wanted
to lead, but then
you can put in all of your
old high school friends
or some of the
other friends too.
So it's a lot of fun--
a lot of small touches
that we're seeing to bring
your current environment
into the application itself.
So let's talk about some
new, awesome markets.
So remember all this before,
and some of the cool markets
that we're seeing with
a lot of crazy growth?
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU:
Where's the next market?
KOH KIM: Where is the
next market, Yoshi?
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: I think
you can see the point in there
in the pictures, which
is Southeast Asia, maybe?
KOH KIM: Yeah.
Southeast Asia.
So Hong Kong, Taiwan has been
rapidly growing really fast
in both terms of revenue.
Southeast Asia-- so places
like Indonesia, Thailand,
India-- tons of
installs, a lot of users
coming in playing games.
But what's also
interesting, Brazil as well.
And so if you see a lot
of rapidly growing stuff,
it's just people are
getting-- smartphones
and mobile devices are actually
the first real computing
device that they've ever had.
So it's really exciting
to see some of the growth
and some of the
opportunities that you
have to get into those markets.
All right.
So what's next?
There, we have a
developer panel regarding
on Google Play
games on services.
That's happening later today.
That's hosted by Dan Galpin.
And later in the
afternoon, Greg Hartrell
will be presenting about where
he thinks Google Play games can
go towards the future.
And so definitely
check those talks out.
Really interesting things,
really awesome people too, so,
that you should get to know.
So thank you for
coming here instead of
going to the US versus
Germany match, which
I am going to go to next.
So--
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: You
can see the second part.
KOH KIM: I can go
see the second half.
But if anyone-- we have
three minutes for questions,
so if you'd like to ask a
question, come up to the mic
and we'll be happy
to answer them.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Can you please talk a
little bit about live events
in Japan, how has it been run--
like those live events that
happen every day for a few hours
and give some rewards, which
is kind of a recent
trend, I guess.
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU:
So, you mean
the live event in the games?
How many games in the
live event in there?
So it depends on the games.
I see it several
games in my work.
And I saw the famous games
has like 20 or 24 live event
in the once time.
And then they have a two
week event, a one week event,
and the special event
is only one day.
That's Japanese famous titles.
AUDIENCE: Are there any
two hour, four hour events?
So twice a day, maybe,
or something like that?
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU:
Four, eight hours.
KOH KIM: It depends.
It depends-- I think
Puzzle & Dragon,
they do something
during lunch time.
But it also depends on the game.
I mean, what a lot of these
game developers in, let's say,
Korea, Japan, all
they do, they'll
analyze-- they'll take all
of their player behavior data
and see where the
most engagement occurs
within certain time periods.
So it's actually
very common to see
most of the sophisticated game
developers, what they would do
is they would identify
where, let's say,
during commuting times or
maybe during lunch hour,
or maybe on a single day
they'd be like, hey, we're
going to do a live
event that's only
going to happen within
this four hours.
You're going to
get certain items,
or maybe certain drops
are going to happen,
that are going to be
more common than that.
That's going to be useful.
So it's their way to change
the balancing within the game
too, so they can encourage
different behaviors
or different types of items
and a lot [INAUDIBLE].
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: And
those are the-- too much short
timing, you have to figure
out the [INAUDIBLE] as well.
So once in the only two
hours, the event, then
everyone's coming in to
[INAUDIBLE] in two hours, which
is, [INAUDIBLE] is getting
cloudy and getting problems.
So recently there's
some Puzzles & Dragons
and some famous titles
doing a release update.
KOH KIM: Yeah.
Because it's hard
to balance that.
And also, play game services,
we have quests, too.
So it allows you to build those
types of events on the fly
without [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
KOH KIM: Yeah, no problem.
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: Thank you.
KOH KIM: 30 seconds.
AUDIENCE: If I'm in
a different country,
do I see a different play store
with different language there,
or is it just one play store?
KOH KIM: Are you on
device or on desktop web?
Because on device, it
will depend on your sim--
it'll depend on where your
account has linked to,
in terms of where you
made your Google account.
But on a desktop web, for
just accessing Google Play,
it'll just show whatever that
based on the IP address itself.
AUDIENCE: OK.
And then you had mentioned
some translation services,
I'm assuming for like the
copy for the Play store,
and then also you said
uploading XML files
that you would use in your
app, does that cost money?
KOH KIM: So if you
want to hire, let's
say, the professional
translation services, what
it does is we kind of help you
connect to those translators
to give you a quote.
In most cases,
there are, I would
say, a lot less than what
you're going to see if you did
go elsewhere outside of our
thing, because of the volume.
AUDIENCE: All right.
Thanks.
KOH KIM: Yup.
No problem.
All right.
Are we good?
Thank you.
If you have any more questions--
[APPLAUSE]
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: Yay.
KOH KIM: If you have
any more questions,
I'm going to go see
a match outside.